this is what it looks like when a flood
hits your neighborhood and you lose
everything we're on the west side of
Houston which just days ago was under
water for this family hurricane Harvey
brought the third flood in four years to
completely ruin their home so what did
you see when you came back everything
got flooded all our furniture all of
everything gone everything like this
exactly our dining room all our bedroom
sets sofa everything gone how does it
feel to be in your four year old yeah
that that's the saddest part because you
know when you see it and you're like we
had you work on it and you decorate it
you see he loves the solar system you
know everything's gone the first time we
walked in when he we came with him on
Tuesday I was taking photos for the
insurance company and he's just went
like this
stop mommy and I'm like what no photos I
don't want bad memories so that was like
it was just like heartbreaking and then
understand he he understands completely
it did the other floods traumatize the
first one was the most traumatizing for
him because you know he would just be
afraid of the water every time it rained
he would just freak out about the first
one even we would rank with it
we start picking up his toys and put it
on top of a table without a state out
anything in there it could be just like
a little bit of rain and you start
picking up this toilet and put it on top
of a table and picked him up and we
would ask me why he's doing sick just in
case it gets but it yeah when people
live their whole lifetime and never see
an actual disaster and I've seen three
centers for your life oh yeah what is
the feeling when you step foot near home
after this huh and it happened twice
before yeah what did you feel the very
first time it was a very devastating
that very downer we were depressed we
were like what do we do we didn't even
know how to do anything this time we
were with a different I think attitude
we just came in let's clean let's do
this let's get everything out I think
that's one of the one of the Bennett
benefits that we got in setting the
experience that we gained from the first
two times so one might be thinking you
know this is obviously not a safe place
to live you've had three floods in the
span of your four-year-old child's life
went up a lot of people say you know why
don't you sell the house and it's one of
the questions we hate the most because
we have a mortgage to pay and it's not
as easy as somebody's gonna come and
purchase a home from you the second time
we weren't even finished preparing the
house from the first blood when we got
hit again and now it's like who's gonna
buy a house three three times in a year
yeah you know
nobody's gonna purchase at home that
kind of commission the home flooded in
1998 and in 2001 before Norman Israel
bought it but FEMA didn't let them
access the records until they owned the
house they said that if they knew it had
flooded twice
they wouldn't have bought it even though
you guys have flood insurance how much
did you come out of pocket for the other
two I would say probably like 50
thousand 50 thousand this one wait I
know
well it's something we don't know we
don't know what we don't know what's the
point you know
the first time they did tell us all this
is just one in a hundred year type of
blood there have been three times in
three years
and that is to be one 500 year flood so
it's like really so I mean I don't know
if it's something that city can do I
don't know if I don't know what it is
but we can put a stab and see what kind
of options we have or they may just
prepare and wait for the next one
you